it wasn't until I was later in in high
school that I had my first biology tutor
who sort of gave me the confidence that
I could be a scientist I was a tutor
because you're acting correct right so I
was on I was on the show blossom from
the oh you were awesome
I was lost on the show block work block
yeah that clear
correct once I met this this woman who
was my biology tutor that was sort of my
my real kind of coming out party of
believing that I could be a scientist I
didn't even have the skill set because I
had I had been paying attention all the
previous years in math and science but
really just doing what I needed to to
get by I didn't really understand the
beauty of science and math and that
whole world until I was later into high
school then obviously pursuing it in
college was you know it was it was a
party so this saddens me you know why
not not your story the perfect I've
heard that before
know that if the that single person
right made a life difference to you
right how many people are missing that
single person who cannot like just I
mean I can I I'm sure we could all run
the stats on it many girls right it is
the first answer good that's the first
name and that's because I mean that's
because of a historical difference in
the representation of women in these
fields and and uh probably a cultural
bias on the part of teachers and and
instructors and and even administration
how much intellectual capital lay
untapped uh in this world do you want a
number document guns and work
I want numbers first give me numbers
don't just say it I don't have them I
think it's a weight this is Startalk
they don't leave you numberless when if
we can put numbers in this situation you
have the number I have the power I
shouldn't have doubted you nor a second
know I'll have the power to give you the
numbers I have the power to get someone
to give you them oh that's how I work I
grab Howard to listen to those numbers
so Mona can I get some numbers please
all right
everyone is monitor Lobby she's a data
journalist did you even know that thing
existed Mona you got some numbers for us
to bring some of this into focus I do I
wanted to try and answer my aims
question as directly as possible so I
wanted to find out how many female
scientists America is missing
and the number that I came to is 80,000
missing meaning they might have been
scientists but some force prevented that
from happening exactly okay exactly okay
and I just took biologists chemists and
a category called other natural
scientists and I worked out how many
women you would need to just get to a
50/50 gender split and that's when I got
eighty thousand so what do you say
eighty thousand it's just eighty
thousand in those professions exactly
you're leaving out engineering and
physics and mathematics mathematics and
all the rest of this yeah okay but
presumably equal access equal
opportunity doesn't require equal
outcome so that that missing number
presumes that if everything were even
then everything would be even right but
we know that we don't have equal access
right my am touched on it in the clip
and it's really really relevant so I
also looked at some of the cultural
barriers that stop women from going into
the sciences now we know that
statistically women are less likely to
be hired by science faculty they're less
likely to be asked to perform
mathematical tasks and they're less
likely to have their academic papers
deemed of high quality and I know that
last bit because of research by a female
scientists called Emma Pearson now what
Emma did was she looked at nine hundred
and thirty eight thousand three hundred
and one academic scientific papers and
she found that the average male
scientist publishes forty five percent
more papers than the average female
scientist so you're saying we're messed
up that's what you're saying that's how
to be messed up numeric in numbers
numbers are showing how messed up you
are that's right